Today we'll be discussing and a little bit in a haste,
of course,
I haven't got much time to do this,
but we'll devote the whole class to the Vita Nova Nova as it is called,
which is Dante's first,
uh,
work.
Uh,
I was going to say first finished work,
but in a way,
it's not a finished work.
It is a deliberately unfinished work.
Dante doesn't really finish many of his works.
He interrupts them,
he breaks off and decides to move on to do other things.
This is the case with the philosophic banquet,
this text of ethics that he,
he goes on writing once he's in exile.
It's true for the text on language.
So cold.
They've Guardiola acquaints about the vulgar language.
The second book he just a warm Mongo on.
Uh,
but it's also true in a way for the veteran [inaudible] ends,
uh,
with a vision.
But we do not know what's going to happen.
Uh,
after that.
This is,
it's a kind of suspension,
uh,
about it.
But this is the first work,
let's call it full work that Dante writes.
The title means a new life,
the new or new life.
So it means probably a youth that describes the story or an autobiographical
account.
Uh,
the lover,
the poet who is,
uh,
who falls in love with Beatrice.
You may remember I called it the first decisive event happening in his early
life immediately after his mother's death,
uh,
and describes is the story of this love for Beatrice who then in the narrative
dies and he goes,
he,
the pilgrim lover,
poet goes on recording,
uh,
the confusion,
the sense of loss that ensues this,
this event of the death of Beatrice.
Uh,
his betrayal's becomes an ethical drama,
uh,
as most lyrical poetry of the Middle Ages.
That's it.
They always dealing with,
with the treacherous presences,
with betrayals,
uh,
with infidelity,
et cetera.
And then he ends up having,
uh,
a final vision.
It's so it's youth,
uh,
it's,
it's the new life to me to above all,
uh,
youth,
but you means many other things,
which I think the narrative will go on.
The meanings of which I think the narrative it will sustain.
New in Italian means means surprising and expected,
even strange,
novel,
marvelous.
It's an in it.
Therefore it gives a kind of a direction to the way we should be reading this
story.
It's a primarily,
well,
uh,
all these meanings are true and it's an autobiography or what we call our,
we'll come to the description of what an autobiography is.
It's also what we call a novel of this health.
Uh,
and other way of speaking about autobiography,
which literally means I write about myself.
So let me say a few things about this structure.
This all by auto-biographical structure,
this former problems before we get into the narrative,
uh,
as such,
um,
from one point of view,
we might,
uh,
a whole agree easily that if you knew that this is,
it belongs,
a bitter war belongs to a mode of province are poets who would,
all right,
but they would call viva life.
It says the word lingers,
continues in Spanish lives.
They said they would write the poems and they would a pen,
a brief account of their lives.
This is true for [inaudible].
They all do that when they would publish their poems.
So we'll say that Dante is writing about himself and inserting the poems as part
of the texture of his own,
uh,
his own life.
But it's an autobiography though the,
the,
the text echos,
uh,
and this model on the most important auto biography written in the Middle Ages.
In fact,
it's written by one who can be called that have founder of the autobiographical
czar.
And it is something Gaston,
who writes,
as you know,
the confessions confessions,
which is,
uh,
a witness,
which is seem him,
it's,
it's addressed.
It's really the story of his life from his childhood in,
uh,
in Africa.
Uh,
he saw growing up,
uh,
as,
as a gifted young rhetorician philosopher turned rhetorician who then moved to
Rome where he becomes a teacher despise unpaid,
but his students moves on to Milan and the whole narrative climaxes with a
conversion.
In fact,
the whole idea of their auto biography for Augustan is that it is a,
it coincides with,
it is coextensive with Eh conversion.
He writes a combo.
He here he achieves his conversion in a,
in a God that in Milan,
uh,
it's a narrative that we may have at some point the chance to go to an and look
at it in some,
in some detail and then goes on writing a,
uh,
a hermeneutics of the biblical genesis as if the new life that he found through
the conversion could only literally issue into a commentary about all beginnings
Genesis as the beginning of all beginnings,
uh,
as it were.
But after we say this and we say,
we can say that Augusta rights,
uh,
in the full awareness that in effect the auto biography has to be the same thing
as a conversion because autobiography demands to voices all the time.
Uh,
it's necessarily ambivalent.
It,
it demands the voice of the narrator who is outside of the narrative and who can
look back.
In fact,
the mode of writing autobiographies always retrospection.
I look back at my life and tried to figure out what are the stages,
what are the events?
What does that makes me now the person that I am?
So there's a sort of necessary distance between the protagonist and the and the
narrator to voices and rake or who knows more then what the protagonist knew.
I am caught in time and I have encountered in my own life from day to day.
And I never know what those encounters really portend.
No.
What do they mean?
Ah,
and that same thing for you.
You have,
uh,
you probably,
I don't know if you hold a that which is the most abbreviated,
uh,
in,
a unit over autobiography,
which is a diary.
You go home at night and you jot down all the great events of the day.
Uh,
but you may over overlook the most important.
You may have had a meeting with someone,
you may have caught sight of some person who eventually 10 years from now we
reenter your life and give a altogether different appearance and direction to
your life.
This is to say that all autobiographical experiments,
like all diary entries are always uncertain and fundamentally false because you
can never really ride.
They can only write about what you know at that point.
And you can never really write about the whole structure of your life to be able
to write about the structure of your life.
You have to die.
That's Augustans idea of the necessity of conversion.
It's a symbolic death by means of which you come back into existence.
You'll come back into life as a new man.
You have a new life and now with that,
from that standpoint of you're being a new life,
you can have all the necessarily detachment to look at your past and decipher
that which was in a haze which was uncertain as things went on.
The other reason why you need this kind of structure in order to buy this double
voice is obvious because if I go on writing about my life without got any sense
of what my life is about,
can you imagine what happens?
I go on writing every single thing that I do,
which means that I would need another life to be able to say,
well,
I got up in the morning and I brushed my teeth and et Cetera,
et cetera.
It becomes a random,
senseless accumulations,
accumulation of facts without any particular meaning or,
or,
uh,
the election.
Dante is aware of this type of complication of autobiographies where you don't
have this kind of autonomy.
We have autobiographical writing.
Writing's beforehand,
you have a kind of self analysis.
Think of of the,
uh,
the one,
the figure that is most powerful for Augustan is,
is David King David in the psalms with a kind of a reflection,
a kind of turning inward and,
and trying to,
to pinpoint the shifts in molds are moral judgments than patients.
So the idea of one's own systems,
but this is really means,
uh,
the kind of internalization of one's life.
Okay.
A gasoline will not do this with digoxin and we'll go,
we'll go into the interiority of his self into the interiority of his
consciousness,
but he will also describe what has happened to him in the public space.
Uh,
he goes inside and outside all the time.
Damn,
please.
Or,
uh,
with turnover you have all read it.
It's really a complicated text from this point of view because for me,
for it being eh,
in autobiography,
it's amazing how little he tells us really and his own life.
It's nothing concrete about this text.
We know that it has taken place in the takes place.
In Florence.
Florence is not even mentioned as a city.
We only infer that it's Florence because at one point there is a description of
a river.
That process by it and which Nantha uses because he has had an inspiration.
Words come to him with the same kind of strength and naturalness with which the
waters of the river flow.
That's the,
that's the implied meaning of that association or the description of our
landscape.
There's a river and and,
and,
and they'll grow.
Fantastic.
Words came to me,
which I I jotted down was the one to remember.
It's the turning point in poetic terms of the Vita Nuova when he addresses,
therefore,
he understands how to write poetry.
He writes a famous line,
women who have intellect of love.
It is a remarkable line though.
[inaudible].
It's a remarkable line,
and they will explain why it's a remarkable line.
It was never written.
That kind of perception was never really part of,
uh,
of the end of the,
say,
the warehouse of a,
of the poetic imagination.
So what does Dan do?
It's,
it's a,
it's a little bit abstract.
This is a kind of a need grammatic account that he gives in.
This is unlike Augustan.
It begins with a reference to the book of memory in that part,
or the book of my memory within which literally has been written.
I find words,
which I can not go on repeating in all,
but I would just transcribe some sentences,
the meanings of them.
So he understand that the,
here we have,
first of all,
it's a book of memory necessarily act of retro spectrum and memory.
It has a number of other implications and dangerous.
What are the implications while Dante is writing?
This is about 25,
24.
Um,
he had,
it's,
it's a provisional retrospection of his growth as a poet.
He certainly knows that memories their mother,
as you know,
of the music.
This is the famous myth,
right?
Uh,
is good.
The old Greek myths,
duck mammary,
uh,
[inaudible] to,
lay with Jupiter from nine successive nights.
And from there copulations the nine muses came into being so mammaries the
mother says,
which means that art is always an act of memory,
eh,
and way of every member in an act of remembrance we could say.
But it has also some,
uh,
dangers that Dante we'll,
we'll go on reflecting about is that if you go on getting caught in the activity
of memory,
you run a serious risk.
The risk of changing your sense of life and your sense of reality into the
phantasms memory.
Cause that's what memory is.
It's called a Juno,
the eye of the imagination.
That's the famous,
uh,
description of memory.
The Greeks of course,
for used to put memory in the heart.
And in fact,
as you know,
uh,
the ancient Greeks used to put them in the heart.
In fact,
as you know,
in Italian or in Spanish,
[inaudible] which really has the etymology and English record I see at the
mortgage of the heart with the member.
Uh,
but in the middle ages,
it's already part of the imagination.
It's called the eye of the imagination,
which means that has a visionary component to it.
And this explains the emphasis of dreams,
vision,
strange operations with which this text is punctuated from the beginning to the
end.
Planetary Pete understands that there is a danger to memory.
And the danger of memory is the transformation of experience into a fantastic
matic reality.
We all live in the world.
It's like you're always looking backwards and you,
you're not Janice,
like you don't look in all directions.
You don't look ahead.
And then people turn against memory.
And the second thing that we get from that little absorb some of the,
uh,
in that part of the book of my memory,
we know that dentists pressing,
so I find words,
which have been the inscriptions of memory.
I'm not going to repeat them all,
but only some of them.
We know the dentist casting himself as the editor of his own book.
That's the double voice.
And this is the double structure of this little text of his,
first of all,
it's a double has duplicity or Lova this Texas,
it's a book of poetry and it's a book of prose.
It's not an unusual structure or Wheaties,
the consolation of philosophy is written like that.
Dante also writes out of Texas like that,
you know,
but what is,
what are the implications,
whether it's a lyrical self who has been in the throes of a great passion for
Beatrice,
who struggles sometimes with,
with uh,
his,
uh,
inspiration.
Wait,
that's the problem he has that one of the crises that he has is that he always
waiting for words to come to him.
He's all,
we were always waiting for beer to still say hello to him.
There is a way in which he cast himself as the passive,
a passive protagonist,
weak willed,
a unable,
uh,
and it sort of believing that the will can direct him whatever,
the real ones.
And that's another problem that we are really going to talk about.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
the final,
he understands that he better get out of that mode.
And in effect,
and I will say this by making your turn,
just talking about the formal structure now,
um,
the whole text is written in the past mode,
the whole text,
that part of the book of memory,
a commemoration of a great event in the private life of love.
And she doesn't even know what it is.
He doesn't even know the woman.
He doesn't even know what the passion is.
And part of what the,
the tangent of this text is to ponder what it is that the passion means and what
it is that it's doing to him and to his mind.
But by the end of the,
of our,
in chapter 42,
which by the way,
let it be said in passing,
it's the,
the division in numbers is completely arbitrary.
We don't know.
That's not the way books were written.
[inaudible] were written in Dante's time.
They was a continuous,
uh,
to save page papers.
And people really believe,
but the modern editor have made it or controversial into $42.
Who,
because they should be 30 and I agree with that.
But let me read the path.
The last passage,
last paragraph,
which is no poetry now ends with pros with a voice of reflection.
Pope pros functions is the work of reflections on the lyrical,
on the lyrical inspirations,
on the immediacy of the lyrical voice.
So that's the double was,
I'm an editor and I'm a poet.
At the same time sometimes the editing,
the notes that he writes,
say nothing about the poem.
They tried to,
sometimes he goes on into fall mode,
uh,
mechanical description about where this solid is divided into two parts.
That doesn't really add much to the inner life,
to our understanding of the inner life of the protagonist.
So this is what he says in 42 chapter 42 after I wrote this song,
it,
which is about the famous vision of Beatrice sitting at the foot of God's
throne.
And so he decides that he has has to go there.
He decides that he has to go and meet her.
That's the last vision.
Okay.
After I wrote a sonnet there came to me and miraculous vision in which I sold
things.
Visionary burden of the narrative is kept up from memory now to vision that made
me resolve to say no more about this blessed one and blessed the Italian,
by the way,
it's a pun on the name of Beatrice,
the one who is blessed.
That one was the better of the good.
Uh,
that's really what it means until I would be capable of writing about her in an
old war way.
So if that's the uh,
and avoidably unfinished,
the quality of the texts,
I can go on to write about her,
I need to do more work and it would do more research and find out what I really
can say about this woman.
So he will stop.
That's what I call an unfinished,
Eh,
and inevitably I'm finished narratives to achieve this.
I'm striving as hard as I can and this she truly knows accordingly,
if it would be the pleasure of him through whom all things live with my wife,
continue for a few more years,
I hope to write of how that which has never written before of any other woman
and then it may please the one who is the load of graciousness that my soul has
sent to behold the glory of its lady.
There is,
there is a blessed Beatrice who can grow.
Rick contemplates the countenance of the one we asked the barometer Sacra
Benetech to Swish through all times,
uh,
blessed and the and and ends with a pan on again,
a Beatrice,
what is the most important?
To me,
the most important point of this paragraph.
The intrusion of the verb of the future.
The only time you find it inherited,
I hope the whole text is contained between an exercise of memory,
an idea of something which is past and attempts in great reviews.
If something is passed you have,
you think that you can even control it.
You can certainly decipher it.
You can hope to extract from it some particular meaning narcissist,
complacently or not,
and then ends with a projection of the self into the future and other work has
to come.
This is the preamble to something more,
which I can not really campaign.
So memory is abandoned.
The work ends with an emerge and within the horizon of the future.
This is really very important.
The limitations of memory and can be understood the only from this point of
view,
because hope,
as you know,
when you think of hope,
hope grammatically,
this is what is the future.
He says,
I hope to write.
There's no future there.
I hope it's in the present,
but hope grammatically is a verb.
As you,
those who have studied a little bit of Latin,
remember,
always takes the future participant.
I hope that I will do this and so I hope I would have done this.
It doesn't work.
I wished I had done that,
but so it takes all,
it's a verbal,
the future.
It is literally also in substantial terms.
It's a virtue.
This is a theme to say,
I hope it's a theological virtue.
Hope which always implies the future.
It says that the past is not really over and done with because once you include
or you intrude the category of hope,
you really believe you can change the meaning of the past.
The things may be happening that whereby all your past errors or your past
mistakes can be seen and will be seen in a new life so much.
Then for this question of,
uh,
the structure I repeat,
we have prose and poetry.
We have the voice of the lover and we have a voice of the editor.
We have a text of memory that at the same time turns against itself,
points out that the mutations of memory and opens to the future through hope,
right?
And you have this idea that uh,
uh,
something amazing is going to happen.
Something,
uh,
that don't,
nothing concrete is being given.
Everything will take place within the self.
It's the moment where Dante Abandons Augusta.
We began by saying,
I began by saying that the mode,
the rhetorical mode that Dante really follows his Augustine's confessions,
which is a text of retrospection.
And then with the commentary on Genesis,
Dante and with,
uh,
what we call a prolapse is a weird word.
It's not so weird,
but we'll,
that means a projection to the future.
Auto biography has this kind of future dimension and cannot be contained.
It was,
it's not over and done and done with the most,
the mode,
which is really just to make this really intelligible to you,
this,
the,
the kinds of texts that is most like what Dante is written in the individual
mover.
It's really Joyce who writes the portrait of the artist as a young man.
That's the way you can really,
if you can not have a conversion,
if you're not,
you can not die as Augustan says you have to do.
When you write,
write an autobiography,
in order to come back as a new man and be able to write your life story and find
out the meaning of your life,
then what you can do is write about yourself with a kind of temporal distance
that is brought by the time I'm no longer the young men are used to,
to be.
But I do know those passions.
I removed myself from them and exactly the same way Joyce does it with a
portrait of the artist.
I said young man,
which hands with a projection of going to a descending the smithy of this whole
writing,
uh,
the,
the forge and forge the epic of,
uh,
of,
of the future.
That's really the,
I mean,
it ends up with a project for the future.
So this is,
this is a kind of,
uh,
mode of total autobiographical writing that Dante really,
prepares and puts forth.
Um,
what,
uh,
happens to this text so much for the,
this,
uh,
you can,
by the way,
you can stop me at any point,
uh,
as a,
as I'm talking,
if you want me to clarify things or we can literally live at the end.
What happens to the text?
It's a love story.
It's a love story of a young man,
um,
who meet at the age of nine.
MMM.
Meet a young woman who is roughly the same age.
He says she's in her ninth year,
doesn't even know who she is,
but fields that kind of bliss and then sees her again nine years later.
So we know that there is a kind of numerical symbolism or running through the
number for Beatrice is three,
three,
three trinitarian number.
She comes off,
she got reappears and he's convinced that this is going to be the love of his
life,
but he doesn't even know what love is.
He does not know what love is,
what he does know at the beginning.
And this is what the part of the,
the whole,
the,
the economy of this narrative,
uh,
really focuses on time to ponder what laugh maybe,
you know,
the culture of the Middle Ages is filled with literature of love.
This could be viewed as one of the many love books or the Middle Ages.
And in case some of you may be looking already for a,
Eh,
a topic for your paper.
You could write about the love books or the Middle Ages,
um,
but are the other love books the famous,
what books are Middle Ages,
which are completely different from the love of books in the Middle Ages coming
before,
uh,
for instance,
the Arthur courtly love of undress couple times.
Would you say you sort of,
you know,
it's a codification of what love is.
Uh,
the idea that love is an art,
the art of courtly love,
that it's obviously natural inner instinct or thrust the passion and yet has to
be changed as if they can be a sentimental education when his to learn how to
contain,
how to hold off excesses,
how to hold off the potential disruptions and violence that love will produce.
There are that the romances of critique and they too are that you may know
about,
which is all about,
uh,
love at the court.
Uh,
the place of pleasure within,
uh,
the,
the unfolding of a responsible life.
Uh,
uh,
there are so many other tech,
a lot of the province are poets from Dante really evokes a,
Dante writes about love.
And let me say a couple of things with it so that you can really,
uh,
it's not the first time that people reflect about love.
Of course,
the Greeks tried to do that and you may remember
Socrates who always wonders what love is.
Is it a figure of speech,
manner of being,
you know,
these are such a thing as love.
It's,
that's just,
uh,
use this figure of love.
Is it a God that possesses me?
It's just a natural instinct and that we call love.
It's on this variety of,
uh,
of passions.
This right of ways of understanding,
of all figure within the state.
The main things that Dante meets.
Beatrice doesn't even know who she is.
It doesn't not know what's happening to him at the age of Eight,
it starts in an involuntary way.
The whole point of this narrative is that things seems to be happening to him.
No,
he's a passive figure,
but even love comes to him.
It's,
he doesn't real it.
He does look for it and in many ways,
look at this passage here or kit in book in Chapter Two,
nine times already since my birth,
the heaven of light had circled back to almost the same point where there
appeared before my eyes.
It's,
it's appeared.
It's an operation.
Something gives itself to him before my eyes.
They're now glorious slate of my mind who was called Beatrice even,
but also did not know what her name was.
She had been in this life long enough for the heaven or fix stars to be able to
move a 12th with a grizzly east.
In her time there is,
she appeared to me or about the beginning of her ninth years,
she's a little younger than he is and that first her,
near the end of my ninth year,
she appeared dressed in the most patrician of collars,
subdued the deckers crimson at that very moment in the speak,
the truth,
the vital spirit,
they want to dwell.
So the most secret chamber of the heart began to tremble so violently that even
the most minute veins,
my body were strangely affected and trembling.
It spoke these words here is a god stronger than I who is coming to dominate me,
to rule over me.
I mean,
this is,
uh,
these are set descriptions,
work leverage.
The point is that he doesn't will it,
he does not know what this is about.
Why,
why does he present himself as and willing this passion?
Because passions because which are unwilling seem to be more important than the
things that we will if they are unwilling.
And they happened to me.
They may have the mark of a secret necessity.
There may be a pattern behind them that I do not know,
but it happened to me.
You see what I'm saying?
I do not have any responsibility about it.
I don't know what that is.
He will find out in time that he cannot go on obeying the rules of the will,
that he has to go on understanding that they will needs to be in turn ruled by,
by reason.
And the other thing that he does is that this is God,
this figure of love.
I said,
God clearly,
literally reconceived.
He has no idea who speaks to him.
Over,
over,
over ranch,
him roll over random.
He takes refuge in the chamber of his house,
the Chamber of his mind.
And there he goes,
uh,
engage in deliriums,
dreams,
uh,
et cetera.
They say all the clinical signs of love,
he thinks that love is a passion that this debilitates them.
This whole problem would come to a head with the first sonnet that highlights,
which by the way,
is really the point of view.
We know,
uh,
[inaudible] 17 years old when he wrote this poem.
Oh,
we know that this is really a kind of,
uh,
sort of,
it's a dream.
It's a poem which appears as a dream,
uh,
which I read in English and this,
so and so's translation.
But it's better than anything I could try to every captive soul.
It's a horrifying dream.
As you can see,
two every captive soul and loving heart to whom this words,
I have composed a scent for your elucidation in my reply.
Greetings or bring for your sweet load sake.
Love the first three hours,
the hours of the time of shining stars were coming to an end when suddenly love
appeared before me.
To remember her really was a pulse.
Me.
Julius loves seem to me holding my heart within her hand and in his arms.
He had my lady loosely wrapped in,
folds asleep.
He woke her then and gently fed to her the burning heart.
She ate it,
terrified,
and then I saw him disappear in tears.
It's a dream,
a horrifying dream about a lady which is asleep,
held in the arms of the Lord of love.
She weighed and needs the heart.
The heart is given to her.
It's a story of clearly how the heart nor riches,
lust.
That's,
that's the,
the,
the sense.
But the meaning,
he says,
uh,
it's a dream.
Another involuntary experiences at dream comes to us without a will,
without wanting it.
And she said,
said the meaning of this,
uh,
the song,
it was unclear.
He writes this on it and sends it out to his fellow poets in Florence.
He sends one of them to the person who is going to become his best friend and
whom this Texas dedicated and who will appear very soon in the text.
His name is weasel Cavalcanti.
We should see him in hell by the way.
None that,
we'll put him in inferno pen and we'll talk about him at length.
And the,
uh,
we don't answers cause that was the fashion is write the poem.
And then by taking your own rhyme scheme is I kind of response,
they go on really writing about this and that.
And,
and,
and we look at our candidate says to him,
well,
you're really right.
You really had the vision,
which means that you can not quite trust love that you really have to turn away.
It's a,
it's a kind of admonition to you move from all of this figments of love and
turned pro philosophical studies.
It's only in the mind that you can find,
and then the pursuits of the works of the mind that you can find some kind of a,
of truth and stability for yourself outside of it.
That is only in the few pursue love.
There's the world of the arrangements,
by the way,
or another,
our physician of the time,
uh,
Dante,
his name was also Dante,
Diana,
he decides to write to him and also writes about the zone of this is,
well,
this really means that you,
you have a humoral problems.
Take cold baths and everything will be okay.
You nearly need,
uh,
need to rebalance,
the new equilibrium for your humerus.
One reduces love,
pled question of bodies position.
I say,
if we're just a disease,
the other one reduces it to a question of,
uh,
loves danger.
Visa VI the stability of the mind.
Dante,
we'll go another with one and will not listen.
Another two,
one no to the other.
The rest of the poem will be that of trying to understand what this love really
is.
A crucial chapters who would appear.
Chapter Eight,
he describes is going to a funeral.
You remember what he sees a dead woman and you,
and you wonder what is the point of this kind of scene.
And the point,
I think that scene is that there is a body and that body is in earth and dead
and that there is no possible connection between him and this dead body.
So that love is not reduceable all the two bodies they need.
There must be some kind of animation.
There must be some kind of soul.
That is our life that accompanies it.
And the,
the,
uh,
in chapter 12,
finally,
Dante seems to be moving a little bit,
uh,
away from this.
A province are this,
this way of describing love in,
uh,
in terms of conventional terms that I have to describe to you.
And he has this other dream about at the Lord,
the god of love who comes to him and says,
it's time for you to put aside all Simulacra,
all fictions,
whole emptiness.
Let me just say a little bit about more this point about love and the kind of
questions of Dante raises whenever we think about love in the modern era,
as you know,
this is not my ideas,
but particularly I believe in them.
Uh,
others have formulated these ideas.
What do we think about love and modern times that the formulation of love is we
understand it today is essentially medieval.
The Greeks do not have this and this understanding of love,
the way the romantic idea of love,
the way we do,
they understand love as an intellectual pursuit,
as,
as an ascent up the ladder of being.
That's the work of philosophers,
uh,
that the,
the,
the minds can go on a,
from the green through the various degrees of a reality and intellectual reality
in one can grasp it.
That is friendship of course,
but it's not the idea of the love of the man for a woman,
which is so crucial tool,
the romantic understanding of love.
The,
the,
the Romans had no understanding that tall about either what the Greeks knew or
what we know.
Uh,
you know,
the most important,
uh,
Latin voice romantic love is for instance,
I think capitalists who talks about love as something to be slightly embarrassed
about.
It's a weakness.
A serious guy that's not involved in oneself.
And this kind of,
uh,
of,
of pursuit is kind of,
you have to do the serious work of,
uh,
of living,
the political issues,
going to the forum,
negotiate,
et Cetera.
But come the province,
our world in the south of France,
the province,
our courts love changes both its meaning and its contours.
Now love is the love of men for a woman.
And it's usually described and even Andrea's Capilano's and they are to three
love or in the Texas of,
uh,
of,
of uh,
uh,
cutting the tour.
It's described this maybe it can be a clan,
the Stein secret relationship in necessarily need not be within marriage cause
marriages are usually a business propositions.
Uh,
it is,
uh,
it is a kind of emotion and that uh,
potentially violence,
in fact,
they had effort is what should,
what is the sociology of love?
Can a noble man fall in love with a Caribbean woman?
Can a noble woman fall in love with a Plebeian man?
So it's a real sort of arrangement about what love can be.
And yet they also describe it.
They always describe it as the experience that causes
insomnia,
loss of appetite.
The lover turns,
pay and can speak in the presence of the beloved.
They go on describing the physical properties of love.
The other Greek revolution about love is what is contained in this text.
He's not the only one that is not the only one to have brought her about.
He's teachers and people that they like to read or cover canteen when it
certainly we're going to the same direction.
Namely that love has to be explored for the changes it brings to the mind.
How can it be,
this is a kind of problem that they raise.
How can it be that I see a woman and the image of that woman obsesses me?
What is it about my mind?
Why do I want to be better than I am?
How am I going to be educated?
But in the height of the light,
in the light of the love that I feel for this woman and an effective,
this kind of metaphysical aspect of love is the special burden of,
uh,
of this text.
Let me just give you an idea.
Uh,
it happens,
uh,
the first time that this happens,
is exactly where the famous poem that I mentioned to you.
That is the turning point.
Uh,
chapter 19.
let me just read this paragraph.
This is a turning point in Dante's understanding of what love is.
Then it happened that while walking down the path along,
which ran a very clear stream,
we guess,
but it's the iron river,
he would say he's not interested in the outside world,
is only interested in what love does to his inner self,
to the story of his mind.
I suddenly felt a great desire to write a poem and I began to think how to go
about it.
What an extraordinary moment.
Finally,
he's not just jotting down words that come to him.
He's just thinking,
this isn't all just about a self that is desiring or willing or unwilling and
who lives that kind of strange world.
Oh,
it's a good thing that things are happening to me because I can't help it.
You know,
I can,
I can give up my whole,
uh,
I can give up my whole exercise of what I can do,
the sense of purpose about what,
what,
what is happening,
changing will into,
into a rational,
uh,
activity.
Now he starts thinking and that began to think I would go about it.
It seemed to me that to speak of my lady would not be becoming unless I were to
address my words to ladies and not just to any ladies,
but only to those who are worthy,
not merely to women.
Then I must tell you my tongue is not out of it.
Yet,
as if moved of its own accord spoken said ladies who have actually,
he says,
women who have intelligence of love with great delight and decided to keep this
words in mind and to use them.
At the beginning of my poem,
later after returning to the aforementioned city reflecting for several days,
I began writing a console and get song,
which for Dante's than the no blues form of a rhetorical form and using this
beginning and they're constructed it to our in a way that will appear below and
it's division that can solve it begins with ladies who have,
who have ladies with intelligence who love.
I wish to speak to you about my lady not thinking to complete her literally,
but talk in order to relieve my heart,
not thinking to complete her praise.
Praise,
uh,
it's a potent of praise.
Therefore religious,
kind of a very close to religious poems.
As you know,
there are so called Lao,
this laudatory we say in English to come back to this too,
to give you a essence of what this kind of poems can be,
the praise which he would like to ask to distinguish from flattery.
You know,
there's a,
between a prey praising someone and flattering someone praising,
uh,
you really going to expect anything in return you praising and it's a kind of
sense that you are just trying to describe and yielding to the Lord and the
power what,
what is in front of you.
Flattery always imply some kind of a circuitous and some sorts of desire to get
something you flatter.
It's a rhetorical,
rhetorical form.
You flatter because it implies a sold some degree of manipulation.
But the most important word it is women who have intellect of love,
intellect.
Finally,
intellect and love are not too disjointed activities of the mind.
It's not what we do.
Cover.
Canty who really believes in parts really believes in a world which is sundered.
One from the other in a fragmentary world was come to that in in fairness,
10 who really thinks that time is all fragmented from itself anyway,
experiences are all fragmentary.
That love.
If I have a passionate,
I can never quite come to understand anything.
In fact,
when I am in the throes of passion,
my mind seasons,
its operations.
This poem is written against Dantes best friends to whom this Texas dedicated.
And so we are forced to think,
and we'll go back with this appointment a moment,
but let me make a brief digression about the relationship between friendship and
love to extraordinary extraordinary
virtues.
We call them passions,
but they're also virtuous.
Is there anything better than friendship?
Is Anything better than love?
But Dante says comprehensive.
This is the part of the radical way of Dante's thinking.
He brings her,
brings us to a point where you really have to distinguish between things that
seem to be equally powerful.
Virtuals and what is friendship?
Well,
the Friday that the Texas dedicated to widow Kabaka,
which means that friendship implies a conversation,
a conversation of mines.
The word conversation was,
you know in Latin means things turning together.
That's why I did mines.
When you are conversing,
minds are turning together in some kind of harmonious turning,
looking for some common agreements and there is a sort of benevolence in pride
in friendship that presupposes even the I the the where you are going to find we
are going up not only its benevolence is the condition for friendship.
It's really the point of arrival.
We've got to like each other even more after we discuss.
We disagree but we are doing it benevolently that's,
that's the gift of friendship.
It's a virtue in the ethics of Aristotle.
It's counter this one of the major virtues and so that's Dante in his own
rewriting of the ethics of our stove,
which is the banquet.
But laugh for Dante here is more important than friendship and it's more
important for friendship because it forces you to think,
it forces you to think something happens to you and that mobilizes your mind.
You got to go looking for the science of love.
You tried to look for are what all sides,
what kind of sign is my beloved sending to me are et cetera.
The mind is engaged in an extended self mode of self reflection.
So intellect and love now low together.
That's the evolution.
When we go back to the theme that I had been with,
which I started,
this is the beginning of the so called sweet new style,
that kind of poetry that the Tuscans right and which is a sort of rethinking of
what the province,
our ports were doing.
The province,
our poets are writing poetry in the mold of I tremble under shade and the uh,
the image of the beloved.
I cannot even tell anybody.
I have to keep my passion away from the flatterers because they are going to
violate my secret.
And so I'll have to always protect this.
I have to protect the identity of their beloved.
He wrestles with singularity and uniqueness to this passion.
The tusk and poet Dante Cavalcanti we need,
sadly,
they come on,
they come along and say,
no,
no.
What matters is that love and become part of intellectual experience and
intellectual assent and knowledge only favors love and love mobilizes the mind
to go on thinking.
See,
I really don't want to to say too much now because we have so much time ahead of
us.
The great debate,
philosophical debates,
the 13th century is always the forest between the so called voluntourists
irrational wrists.
Very simple,
don't.
So the volunteers are those who believe that if I want to know something,
I have to love first to love is crucial to my knowledge.
If I uh,
you know,
probably you remember well from your own early Jews when some of you would be
interested in and the boy or the boy and the girl,
someone would say,
Oh,
you really love that person.
What do you mean?
I don't even know him.
I don't even know her.
That's really issue.
If you love so that you may know that's the position of the voluntourists.
No,
no.
Others would say you have to know first a no,
the,
you may love and they said they're fierce debates.
Dante,
circumventing all of us intellect and love.
I like the two feet that carry us along and you move one and you move the other.
And only this work in your walk without being hobbled as he will be later when
he starts in fan.
So this is the great change what you call the sweet new style.
And the sweet new style means therefore a highly philosophical,
highly intellectual kind of poetry and poetry where the woman or the level of a
woman can take you up to the divinity,
love through love.
And the understanding that that which rules the world is not just an idea,
it's just rough and therefore love is the only way of coming to it.
And,
and,
and for showing it.
Uh,
and some examples of this kind of,
um,
of uh,
experience will,
will happen very soon or one to,
um,
uh,
I want to mention this great poem,
that he,
he describes this little sourness,
what he,
he,
which also,
uh,
which sorts of,
pursues immediately after chapter 20.
Uh,
let's look at the sonnets.
The
after this consona had become.
This comes on about women who have intellect of love have become rather well
known.
One of my friends who had heard it was moved to ask me to write about the nature
of love.
That's not what he forget about the,
the experiences about being sleepless.
Dante starts as a province or poet.
He's now refining the idea and wants to think about the nature of love,
philosophical idea about love having without losing sight of Beatrice,
having perhaps from reading my poem acquired more confidence in me than I
deserve.
So thinking that after my treatment to the previous team,
it would be good to treat the theme of love and feeling that I old them to my
friend.
I decided to compose a poem.
Dealing with love is,
I wrote this note,
which begins love in the gracious heart or a single thing.
It's when it's sadly,
we with another poet of the sweetness is the father of the sweet new styles
tells us in his poem,
one can no more be without the other than can be reasoning mind without its
recent nature.
When he loves moons creates them,
etc. Etc.
So this is the shift now,
the full awareness that learning about love,
Dante scanned through the school of the philosophers,
you know that to learn about this,
this means that this whole text really is traversed by two interrelated themes.
Two stories,
two thematic strains running through.
One is the store over love for Beatrice.
Dantes love for Beatrice and way of understanding what love is.
Is it,
is it,
is it uh,
uh,
physical impulse?
Is it a demon?
Is it a figure of speech?
Is it a simulacrum,
another fiction that we tell each other or not?
And he goes home learning about this.
The harder thematic strain of this text has to do with learning to be a poet.
Dante is toso telling us the story of his poetic growth,
how he begins imitating the province are poets imitating now the pores of the
suite and your style.
And finally finding his voice and how the two themes really shed light on each
other.
Because I can only understand this about love.
And if I understand really things about love and not Rios is understood,
I can really go on writing about the poem,
about the,
of writing poems that nobody else can go right in,
which is a famous promise,
the hope expresses in chapter 42 and the fucking own writing about love in a way
that nobody else has ever written.
It means that I understand love more than others have understood and that any
rate,
the great poem that he starts riding when he's in a sense even,
uh,
in,
in a kind of a,
um,
a rivalry with,
uh,
with,
um,
it certainly appears in the force on,
at the stars.
Um,
here I could mention 20,
uh,
21 are the power of love.
Born in my lady's eyes were now it's normally about the nature of love,
but he goes on trying to find love within Beatrice.
It's not the god of love that has been abandoned.
It's not a conceit of love.
It's not,
the words is strange and a dramatic words of love that have come to him from
Oracle's and traditions.
Now that is love is love for the concreteness of Beatrice herself.
As I said earlier,
very much in passing,
uh,
the text,
an extraordinary sonnet.
I read,
I read an Italian,
a couple of lines,
a few lines,
so you can,
you can,
you can hear the sound of this,
this,
this poem.
Chapter 26,
this is about Beatrice,
the apparition of Beatrice.
She calls by through the streets and the world is silent.
We'll force silence is a kind of general oppression,
but also she's wrapped in a kind of mystery.
And in an op inapproachable light,
there's always some kind of distance.
This is the poem,
such sweet the courtroom.
Uh,
page 57 of this edition,
Chapter 26 in such a gentle grace at 10,
my ladies greeting as she moves the lips can only tremble into silence and nice.
They're not attempt the case,
her moving benign recruited in humility and touched by all the praise along the
way.
She seems to be a creature come from heaven to earth,
manifest a miracle.
So we are now Dante peers as this a poet who carries because of love,
heaven and earth mixed up in his head.
Um,
Beatrice brings heaven down to Earth and asks of him that he can rise up to
have,
these are the words in Italian.
Listen to their petitions,
the sounds,
the n sound,
Dan,
to Genteel a Tom Harness the power [inaudible] when they love through,
we salute your new lingo.
The van [inaudible] Muhtar at York [inaudible] and Siva,
centennial,
Shilo,
God and source of prey.
Only praise can come,
uh,
toward,
in,
in her direction.
And finally,
how does he really,
how does Dante really get out of this sense of work?
Uh,
constant wonder.
Cause that's a poem about wonder to Beatrice appears and it's a miracle wonder.
And that's,
and that's how you start thinking.
As soon as you believe that what you perceive is a wonder,
the urine,
quite understand.
You want to go on trying to understand it.
Now that's the state,
that's the heart of the effort of reflection,
right?
Um,
so this is kind of a sense of constant perplexity great excitement at the you
will be.
It is not.
Beatrice has died.
Her death appears around chapter 29.
Uh,
how real can she be now that she said,
well,
how are you going to relate to someone who is dead and none too,
we'll do that,
which probably some others can go do.
We tried to find a replacement and we'll go looking for someone who looks
exactly like her or reminds him of her and then find this chapter 32 33 34,
this woman who has a lot of so much mercy,
sense of mercy for him,
that he's very drawn to her and he understands that in the measuring,
which he tries to duplicate Beatrice,
then their love for Beatrice was not really singular that his own project was at
stake here.
Either you believe in the singularity of the figure you love or if you believe
in the duplication,
then you are undercutting your own project.
So he's caught in all this drama's till finally sees some pilgrims and this is
really the great direction.
And with this,
I will stop and see if there are some questions.
See,
uh,
chapter 40 some pilgrims,
you know,
that uh,
um,
pilgrimages.
It used to go to Santiago de Compostela as they do now.
Then I used to go the famous from the north of Europe,
the so called they,
we've got two generalists on it.
They will go to the via Frankie,
Jenna as it is cold that goes from the north following a particular path or to
Rome.
And he sees some pilgrims are going deco.
Romae.
Uh,
there he see some pilgrims going to Rome and this is the poem he writes.
and this is extraordinary poem.
Ah,
pilgrims.
He addresses them.
They don't listen to him.
They know nothing about him.
He addresses them moving pensively along thinking perhaps of things at home.
You Miss.
Could the land you come from be so far away as anyone might guess from your
appearance that you show no sign of grief as you pass through the middle of the
desolated city.
This is phrase and normally is used for Jerusalem.
Desolate.
We abandoned city.
This is foreign stock.
Like people who seem not to understand the grievous way to wool,
it has to bear.
If you'd stop to listen to me speak,
I know from what my sign heart tells me you would be weeping when you leave.
This place lost is the city source of blessedness.
And they're not words that could be said of her with power to humble any man to
tears.
This is,
it's really another great shift in the movement of the poem.
He sees pilgrims who are going somewhere and he realizes that he's not like
them.
He's not going anywhere.
He is moving and circles and if you move in circles you get nowhere.
Now is something happens around him that will uh,
in many ways shake him from that kind of circular self absorption in which he
finds himself.
And the second thing is that he understands this is an extraordinary poem.
We did it again for yourself.
So you have a chance.
He says,
he understands that for me theology has been constructed about Beatrice is an
absolutely private mythology.
It means nothing to anybody else.
You who come from afar and he's like them because he too is or they are.
They are separated.
Pensively a word that implies suspension,
the same word to think and to be suspended.
It's the same etymology in Latin,
right?
They are the they're,
they're halfway there.
Here now going through Florence,
going somewhere to a destination and nostalgically separated from the world.
The left behind and Nantais two is not going anywhere,
but he doesn't have Beatrice with him and has no idea of where he is though I
like the pilgrims where to go above all this.
If I were to tell you anything,
you would understand that this is a this or a density by you do not know and
implication is you not care.
My mythology is private.
The effort I have to make is to transform my private mythology into public
discourse.
This is the transition from the Vita Nuova to the divine comedy.
The divine comedy would be a text where finally Dante,
we'll go on literally,
he attract theatricalizing literary staging his own passion through the passions
of others,
involving all others in his discourse,
in creating what I would call a public mythology.
So this is really the most important moment and that which ends with another
journey of the mind,
that who will make the next one beyond the sphere that makes the wider round
passes the Cya reason for my heart and your intelligence and love and tears and
Doug with the surgeon it on high,
etc. Here he sees beauty is far away and decides to undertake his journey,
the journey of knowledge,
the journey of exploration,
of the journey,
which will be,
uh,
which is the journey of life and which is the journey that we'll be at the heart
of the,
uh,
comedy or the divine comedy with which we start next time.
Um,
so this is really,
this is the kind of,
uh,
experience,
poetic experience that Dante,
we'll,
uh,
we'll go on.
Uh,
uh,
at the start.
It's still a young man.
Um,
uh,
he's exploring a lot of personality.
He's gathering all the voices around him,
but he internalizes them.
There are no,
it's not,
it's still the kind of encyclopedic text that the divine comedy will necessarily
be what he has to involve all these courses or whispers or,
or groans whole noises.
Uh,
the whole world is to speak through his port.
Oh,
that's part of,
uh,
the most inclusive vision rather than excluding anything that this is a time is,
is it an effort to try to find himself as a port with a project.
And that project will be necessarily a project in the future.
There is no port that I know in the western tradition,
which is so given to the ideal of the future and who is more of a poet of hope.
Then Dante is,
I call him a lot of things and that we'll call him a lot of things are call him
the,
the poet of exile,
which he is,
I call him the point of love,
which is I call him the port of peace,
which he is,
there's any Renick,
uh,
thrust underneath his whole,
even his polemics fierce polemic.
Uh,
but above all and now from now,
he appears as the poet of hope in the knowledge that hope is the most realistic
of virtues because it tells us that the past nor even a past may be dead.
That really despair is the most crucial our sin that one could have English in
this universe.
Belief is to say that things are over and done with damper says,
I'm not done yet.
I still have a project that can even begin to tell you about it.
But let me stop now because I have other things to do.
That's the substance of his poem.
And in this sense,
it's a preamble,
a preparation for the the 30 comedy.
And since I'm trying to give you a sense of dentist,
own life is a fresh and bone kind of guy that he was,
uh,
what happens after this?
So Paul Beatrice has died literally 1289.
She dies.
Dante now is married.
Mary's,
uh,
a woman who will never mention,
um,
the belongs to him,
a decent family and not in a,
in Florence,
the Donati troublemakers and [inaudible] like,
uh,
and Dante.
We'll enter public life and this public life,
which also means that he will have a great interruption to his intellectual.
And it is intellectual pursuits till in 1302,
as I probably remember,
I mentioned his,
his banned from Florence has to go into exile and once he's in exile and his
production or start again,
start writing about the language,
the theory of language,
the first treatise on language in the Western world.
Did I text the VA of,
of,
uh,
ethics,
which is the banquet.
Uh,
and then the divine comedy will begin next time or find them in the middle of
the,
his,
his journey,
which is Ken top one.
But since we have a few minutes,
uh,
who have questions,
oh,
I said a lot of things.
I hope it was a,
I go back to some of these things.
So,
oh,
questions.
Well,
this is not exactly about your lectures about the texts.
Um,
do do you recommend that we go is civic texts that you recommend on the syllabus
or I already own the Mandelbaum translation.
Is that usable for this course as well?
Yes.
The question is,
do I recommend that the students stick to the texts that I mentioned in the
syllabus or can they go and using other texts such as Munda bumps,
translation.
And the answer is yes,
you can.
Uh,
it's a very good,
uh,
Munda bombs.
Translation is a very good translation.
I don't use it for one simple reason because he said,
dear friend of mine,
he probably will hear me now.
Everything will be all record poets have a weakness when they translated dude
out of great love for the Texas.
But the Dar this idea,
look at this,
I can do little one better.
I didn't even banter and he lapses into that and have told them I'm more than
once.
I like this a unpretentious translation by Saint Claire Pros.
Sometimes it's wrong.
I will tell you when he does his blatantly wrong.
Uh,
but you can use Mandelbaum or if you have single term or you have darling and
Martinez or if you have a actual,
which I think is really better than all of these Hollander's Robert Hollander,
uh,
actually translation is by his wife Jean.
Uh,
so that you can use any translation you want.
They are not really all that different from each other.
It's usually the sound.
And of course Manda bomb as a poet,
as a sense of the rhythm in English.
Ah,
absolutely.
Yes.
Love as a process of acquiring knowledge is different or better than friendship
or like the harmonious,
yeah,
the question is very good.
First of all,
and this,
uh,
why should I make a claim that love is a process of knowledge is better than
friendship,
which are singling out that which is one of the dramas of the Vita Nuova book
dedicated to our [inaudible] to his best friend.
We talk up content and yet it's about Beatrice.
And when Kaaba can't appears,
he says,
forget about love.
Uh,
just,
you know,
turn to philosophy,
uh,
and the Sauna Ted is very well known and that I quote in some piece Hurghada Ah,
so there is a tension between the two of love and friendship and we agree and
you seem to be agreeing with the very generic,
not unusual or the scripture that I make of friendship.
A friendship is really the language of philosophers,
right?
Uh,
philosophers who are get together and believe in thought and believe also that,
you know,
friendship is a great virtual,
there's a lot of dramas within friendship and in,
in,
uh,
in literature,
friendships I and 12 do each other.
I'm a better friend than u s to me.
Uh,
I'm a better friend to you than you are to me.
As soon as you talk about that kind of rivalry,
you realize that passions also are getting to that process.
But I would say that Dante,
I understand that to imply here that love is better than friendship.
Exactly.
Because it forces,
it does violence on our ways of thinking because it forces us never to take
anything for granted and in and of itself.
Because listen,
this is moving be some things that you find very romantic.
People can find very romantic.
The idea that a love,
y'all going to be surprised by what the science of Lavar and you bleed with this
of the 80 of love.
Whereas in friendship,
you really have a sort of the clarity of an exchange in love.
You're going to have the secret science that lovers can give a charter.
To me,
a great texts that may be Dante.
I'm sure Dante red is really all very difficult and read over.
It's the stories,
great stories,
but at the story of Pyramids and Bay,
I an old lovers who can see the smallest stuff chink in the war through which to
communicate and old inventing this that comes with,
in a sense,
it's really with the idea that love can urge,
can I say,
can force us to think about in ways that we could never really imagine because
it is tied to the imagination.
Okay.
That's what I would say are the questions.
I think that that's it.
I will see you next Thursday with a cantal one,
et cetera.
Thank you.